same i don't drink
at all actually
when it comes to psychedelics
there's obviously a connection between
psychedelics and consciousness and there
seems to be some tenuous or maybe even
direct connection between consciousness
and these entities
whatever we want to call them aliens or
whatever
do you see that and if so
what is that connection
i think it's just basically simple
telepathy it's inevitably where uh
communication will go for humans
i think
uh to to a great extent people already
experience this phenomena
some in a much more highly developed
way than others
and i think for beings
that are
always being described as being
emotionless and cold
to me that is merely a sign that
facial expressions have become obsolete
for them uh they're they're going to
communicate a greater richness of what
they mean
inflections and emotion and all that and
no need to
have
anything represented by
uh
muscles on their face contorting in
certain ways this really is kind of an
unusual thing because i think humans are
pretty much the only critters that
communicate that way there's all kinds
of things that animals
do to communicate in terms of
sounds and posture and sorts of things
but i think for advanced consciousness
telepathy is inevitable